I do want to talk about your book be
useful seven tools for life because I
read this book yesterday and there's so
much in here that as I said if I had
just seen your only your action movies
over the years uh I in especially in the
early ones I would think well this man
he's a great action star but then as as
you started to make other movies and uh
and I got to interview you and be around
you a couple of times I saw how
hilarious you are how funny you are
naturally and that's in you I thought
okay there's more in this book that
comes out that I never imagined for
example you say that and and and I would
have thought if you have to define the
self-made man in Hollywood it would be
Arnold Schwarzenegger you come from a
very poor part of Austria you grew up no
running water um and you didn't speak
the language and you came here on unite
managed to not only be a bodybuilding
Champion but a biggest movie star in the
world and Conquer politics you do all
these things and you overcome all these
challenges and in your book you say you
can call me whatever you want you can
call me schnitzel you can call me Arie
do not call me a self-made man what do
you mean by that well it's um I know
that people when they call me a
self-made man it's a compliment they
mean it as a compliment but I also at
the same time want to make it clear that
a self-made man means that there is no
one that helped me that I made myself
which is not true I mean my parents
helped me um my father my mother my
teachers helped me my coaches helped me
I had ERS bodybuilding uh coaches and
weightlifting coaches that helped me I
had Joe weeder uh who was kind of like
the king of bodybuilding and fitness in
America bring me to America and make my
dream become a reality got me an
apartment when I came to America got me
some money so I could get started here
and become the greatest bodybuilder of
all time um it was you know the agents
and the producers that helped me to get
then into movies um so and I remember
5.8 million people voted for me to
become governor of California how can I
say I made myself self Governor right
it's wasn't it's not a dictatorship or
anything like that so so I think that I
got a help I got to help from millions
and millions of people and I want to
have people understand that that I know
that I'm a product of a lot of help
because that's important to each one of
us to know that that we product of a lot
of help because that makes you then go
and feel responsible also to go out and
help other people because a lot of young
people and people that are helpless
people that are poor people that just
don't know how to make the next move to
help them because we were helped so
let's help them so this is what made me
an enthusiastic kind of public servant
someone that got involved very
enthusiastically with Special Olympics
in the beginning in the 70s and create
weightlifting for special Olympians and
become the international coach for them
uh that's what got me involved in the
president's Council on Fitness and
travels through all 50 states um and
give something back and promote health
and fitness I started after school
programs and then eventually I ran for
governor when everyone said Arnold
you're
insane uh because you're going to miss
out on two movies a year
which you make $20 million a movie
you're missing out on all that money for
becoming Governor are you crazy and I I
tell people I said look every dollar
that I made was because of America I
became rich and famous because of
America not because of Austria not
because of Germany or any other place
America so it's it's natural for me to
want to give something back so it
doesn't bother bother me at all not to
go go and make movies for a few years
yeah there surprise in this book is you
talk a lot about failure and um it it
really uh resonated with me because I am
very aware of all the things that have
gone you could perceive as going wrong
in my life at different points and then
I later on look at them as kind of
strange gifts and I realize how much
they they help me you make this point
about bodybuilding which is built into
the fabric of bodybuilding is failure
because you need to grow the muscle you
need to push it to the point of absolute
failure recover then add more weights
and you need to push it to failure again
so it's rep in a weird way bodybuilding
is repetitive failure over and over and
over again which I had never really
thought about yeah and that is
why um I tell people
that what makes you sometimes not be
successful is your fear of failure and
and as soon as you become kind of
friends with failure and you say to
yourself wait a minute Michael Jordan
talks about he became the greatest
basketball player because he missed
5,000 shots and he screwed up 280 some
uh games and all of this and that's what
made him the greatest basketball player
so it's failure where we learn really
the most and in bodybuilding it's buil
in that you do the exercise like you say
until you fail in weightlifting you go
and lift until you fail because it's the
only way you know how much you can lift
is if you go all out and always lift
Beyond of what you can lift and then you
know exactly what you can do I I I
missed the 500b bench breast at least 10
times in different competitions but the
11th time I did it you know so I was I
didn't feel like I was a failure I just
felt like I have to do train more and so
so I think the key thing is to tell
people don't be afraid of failure
because it makes you kind of like freeze
and not make a move forward be friends
with with that and understand that from
failure we can learn more and therefore
let's go all out and just feel free of
that and not be worried and and Afraid
all the time I also didn't realize just
how much I mean there all these you know
cliches no pain no gain and and you talk
about that you're very just you say look
there's a lot of cliches out there but
here's the reality of it but when you
talk about lifting and the pain that's
involved There's real pain involved
that's why I never got into professional
bodybuilding okay
is be excuse me what do you mean I'm
sorry no no no you're I have the frame
for it I have the natural uh genetic
disposition absolutely thank you see
there's someone here who knows who I
think we should respect he seemed very
genuine when he what uh what kind of
mirros do you
use I got them from a circus Arnold why
do you
ask they were free and I love them I
have a massive chest whenever I look at
then I see these other mirrrors and I
Spit on
them um but it's it's that you became
comfortable with paint and you were you
were kind of almost it's almost sounds
like you were addicted to not in a bad
way but addicted so addicted to uh to
working out I love this section of the
book that as a Young Man 15 16 years old
you broke into a gym because it wasn't
open on the weekend and you wanted to
work out now I've broken out of gyms I
have never broken into I've never broken
into a gym that intensity was always
there wasn't it it was well our
weightlifting Club was in a stadium and
so on the weekends there were always
games soccer games because it was
underneath the stadium and so you were
not allowed to go in underneath where
the wrestling club was where the boxing
club was the weightlifting club and all
that because it was for the soccer
players and uh so I had to kind of sneak
in so what they did on Friday night was
I did I opened the lb match of the
window on top M and so that from the
outside I can open up the window and
then crawl in and sometimes one time it
was I forgot to open it and I just broke
the window and and I and I climbed into
the into the the back and then I worked
out for hours and hours and hours it was
like absolute heaven but what is
important here is is to recognize that
your
brain and your your mind is no different
than the muscle so the muscle grows uh
by you know pushing it and going through
pain and so discomfort but the same is
with with your head that if you really
want to grow as a person and if you want
to get tough you got to go through pain
you know you should not shy away this is
a lot of times today with today's youth
you know when they talk about you know
the boys are having a problem the girls
having a problem this is a problem that
is a problem everyone has a problem
problem it's like they're getting softer
MH and they're not willing anymore to
kind of take themselves through this
pain period and through the discomfort
everyone wants to be in com in Comfort
people kids want to sleep in uh to 7
8:00 at night when I when I sleep longer
than
6:00 I already hear my father's
Voice who has been dead for more than 50
years but I still hear his voice Arnold
be useful mhm because that that's what
my dad always said and he always would
say he says do you think this country
was built by people sleeping in no this
country was built by people that were
able to work hard to work their ass off
and to go through torchure and to go
through pain and to do all that and so I
was that's what motivates me because I
don't want to go and lie around and live
live in comfort you have any G vacation
of course when we go skiing I go to S
Val yeah then I live in Comfort I sit
out in the jacuz after skiing and all
that stuff but I mean throughout the
year it's all about okay we got to go
and do something move the things forward
and if I don't have enough to do with my
own work then you do some stuff for the
community so there's always things to do
and so this is what I'm trying to teach
people is to make this life rich not to
exist but to live and living means
really to go all out 24 hours a day yes
you sleep 6 hours a day or if you need 7
hours so be it but the rest of the time
there's so much that we can do well I
need 15 hours of sleep 15 hours no good
baby
yeah and then I need to sit in have bath
of heavy cream how many Sony you
remember you just have to pour the cream
into the tub how many times you have to
change diapers during the
night and you need some
[Laughter]
bottle